after the political the personal Joe
Biden crossed the border to begin his
day of ancestral exploration in County
louth's Coulee Peninsula his ancestors
the Finnegans left the area for a new
life in America in 1839 the last major
landmark they would have seen was
carlingford castle where the president
was given a tour
as the rain poured down President Biden
arrived in Dundalk it was time for a
short Walkabout meeting local business
owners before heading to a pub somewhat
and probably called The Windsor here a
clearly relaxed president felt at home
in a sense I know why my ancestors and
many of your relatives left during the
famine
and uh but uh you know when you're here
you wonder why anyone ever want to leave
I mean it
so it's good to be back it was however
also the venue for the first gaffe of
the presidential visit paying tribute to
his distant cousin Rob Carney a former
Irish Rugby International he said this
you see this tie I have with the
Shamrock on it this was given to me by
one of these guys right here it was a
hell of a rugby player and they beat
that little black and tans oh God
clearly confusing New Zealand's old
blacks for the reviled British
paramilitary Force the black and tans
which tried to brutally suppress Irish
Independence it was a blip on a day the
proud irish-american otherwise appeared
to enjoy look at this Air Force One
right here that's pretty cool man his
next round of engagements returns to a
more political theme in Dublin meetings
with the Irish Prime Minister and
president and addressing a joint session
of the Irish Parliament we can expect
his comments there to stick more tightly
to script
Stephen Murphy Sky News in County louth